dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on iifa here there
was a previous episode on a technique
where the inputs were a source video of
ourselves and a target actor and the
output was a video of this target actor
with our facial gestures with such an
algorithm one can edit pre-recorded
videos in real time and the current
version only needs a consumer webcam to
do that this new version addresses two
major shortcomings one the previous work
relied on depth information which means
that we needed to know how far different
parts of the image were from the camera
this newer version only relies on color
information and does not need anything
beyond that whoa and two previous
techniques often resorted to copying the
footage from the mouth and adding
synthetic proxies for teeth not anymore
with this one I tip my hat to the
authors who came up with a vastly
improved version of their previous
method so quickly and it is probably
needless to say that the ramifications
of such an existing technique are
far-reaching and are hopefully pointed
in a positive direction
however we should bear in mind that from
now on we may be one step closer to an
era or a video of something happening
won't be taken as proper evidence I
wonder how this will affect legal
decision making in the future thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time